calling for like eight years and you
really shaped my appreciation for
gratitude once you go there you don't
need anything else
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real
for real documented
question about kind Candor yes when
someone has food stuck in their teeth do
you tell them or do you hope that
they'll just go away on its own
imma go away on its own
kind of guy I actually think there's
something else going on with this
question this falls in the category of
like massive things that don't [__]
matter I'm from the 80s and 90s we made
fun of each other for much more
aggressive [__] than that fair enough
Hi how are you I'm Francesca such a
pleasure Francesca nice to meet you
appreciate you coming thank you for
having me how's it going good good so
one thing that I think people don't
realize is how substantially underrated
grapefruit slices are
they're really delicious like honestly
why am I miss laughing they're [__]
good this [__] grapefruit super ripe
when grapefruit is right it's [__]
legit yo fruit is [__] nature's candy
foreign
the fuel of my ambition is like this
beautiful mix of like gratitude and even
like micro guilt it comes from such a
place of like [__] I'm so happy and like
so many people aren't that like I'm like
very inspired on a daily basis to say
something and change the perspective in
some way that might help someone start
to achieve more happiness all right
let's take some questions from the crowd
now uh young Agency on Earth I'm very
curious if you built a machine yeah what
are some of the payroll decisions
trying to make no profit for as long as
possible so Vayner started no nine first
two years AJ really ran and I still had
to run the business plus I wrote crush
it and the whole time we poured all the
money back into business the pivotal
decision was feeding the business not my
ego
or my bank account or my vices
here
I had an interaction with a guy around
gratitude and it was just like very
interesting I was just like yeah once
you go there you really actually don't
need anything else the Simplicity of the
Gratitude framework like if you're just
actually grateful for what you have
actually for the littlest things versus
envious for the [__] that you don't have
everything's just better every single
problem you have gets better even the
most extreme things like are you
grateful for the time you had with
somebody you loved you know that kind of
[__] gratitude wins
I feel like there's like a stepping
stone or something that or pivotal
number
no I think it was just a I listened to
positive people around me I just limited
envy and jealousy and I leaned into
optimism and gratitude and I've been
practicing it for 40 [__] years and
here I am humans are byproducts of the
information and the energy they decide
to consume this is why I get so crazy
just about like people who want to like
stay in unhappiness if you're deeply
unhappy instead of blaming everyone else
for it put in the work to get out of it
because you can't I believe in people I
[__] believe in you like you can do
it one can create their luck by
acknowledging right in this minute as
you watch this [__] video or listen
to it on podcasts that you're like [__]
it everyone has a [__] it moment that
lady just now earlier just before like I
quit my job to start my own agency I saw
you four months before and you were like
just do all the content I was like yeah
thank you I'm proud of you thank you
congrats got it I was there like I just
heard you say it do it and I was like
[__] it it was my that was was my time
and we're all affected by that I'm just
one human there's [__] lots of people
doing different versions of this if you
want to find positivity it's everywhere
there's just way too much momentum right
now of people looking for a negativity
what they're doing is they're avoiding
accountability it gets really cozy to
blame Perfection for not doing [__] oh
you don't get a Jillian I'm a
perfectionist that's why I can't put out
this video I'm a perfectionist no you're
not you're cute with your words and
you're using as an excuse to not do
because you fear failure you're not a
perfectionist you're of an avoider
people just decided that everyone else's
life is perfect like you have no idea
what's going on in someone's head or
there are four walls behind their door
it's just not [__] true all that
energy to judge others for their
perfection or what they did wrong it's
all outward what about putting it on
yourself
daily B
hope you got some value out of the video
love all of you leave a comment with any
question you got for me I'm going to
clip a bunch out and also in the
comments let me know what really stood
out like what one piece of today stood
out for you
peace
[Music]